bon alors c'est quoi l'idée dessus au
milieu et l'idée c'est vraiment deux
[Musique]
oh
voilà sur les champs aujourd'hui pour
aller voir la nouvelle boutique chaumet
qui ouvre alors c'est la quatrième ou
cinquième boutique à vélizy 2 il ya
chaque les il ya sébastopol 30 séries
quatrième boutique nouvelle boutique
l'idée c'est là pour la marque d'un
fichier un côté luxuriant se positionner
à côté de samsung et apple qui ont
ouvert leur boutique sur les champs
la plus belle avenue du monde je pense
pas que ça va être la boutique la plus
rentable en tout cas ça permet vraiment
la marque de montres est montée en gamme
de montres etc sont des produits
d'excellente qualité des produits de
luxe
même sur la plus belle avenue du monde
le luxe à la française donc on va les
voir ça alors est ce que mon monde qui
attendait bien maintenant fait xiaomi a
dit qu'il y aurait beaucoup de cadeaux
aujourd'hui pour les premiers arrivants
la rada il ya déjà du monde ça ou qu'à
13 heures au grand public la glotte
trouve comme une over ministre comme ça
surtout pourtant bien connu quand il
boit du thé porte ouais très bien
[Musique]
alors tu as l'air à moitié endormi toi
c'est dur ils savent aller seul ça va
après il ya plein de nouveaux tricks ça
c'est un petit vélo alors c'est un vélo
électrique suppose bon on connaît déjà
la trottinette
on connaît déjà le nam bô d'ailleurs on
en reparle très très prochainement ça
parce que je les ai en test à la maison
il ya beaucoup de d'écouteurs bluetooth
ennemis fidget pub jouer anti stress
voilà donc si vous êtes stressé
vous avez ça c'est assez rigolo des
écouteurs sans donner un coup de tous
les côtés si vous voulez avoir la grande
classe à dallas
vous avez les lunettes de repos shiomi
19,99 pour l'instant vraiment fait le
plein un nouveau produit à vous avez les
souris sans fil
vous avez le kit de tournevis enfin y'a
pas un produit qu'on n'avait pas et il
ya longtemps et qui ont débarqué très
fraîchement avec cette nouvelle boutique
sur les champs elysées de la plus
célèbre conte un peu de tout
l'écosystème de shiro me parce que vous
avez une offre à plus de 360 degrés
qu'on connaît beaucoup l'électronique
mais là vous avez dû jouer vous avez
plein de trucs c'est assez hallucinant
casque filaire haute résolution ça on
l'avait déjà vu mieux dans côté un peu
plus smart home avec tous les capteurs
pour la sécurité de son intérieur tous
âges avaient du coup il n'y a pas
longtemps que vous avez amené d'embryons
bagagerie séché au mieux des coûts les
prix en même temps le sac qui coûte quoi
6,99
on va vraiment la politique de prix
hyper agressive de xiaomi de la valise
voyez à moins de 60 euros à quelque
chose près même des parapluies la bbox
bouilloire électrique connecté
déclenchable tous très pratique ça hyper
pratique qu on a même le filtre alors le
filtre à eau lui il est par contre je
pense qu'il va pas du tout être
collectées ou si on ne voit pas à quoi
que ça c'est la lampe de bureau qu'est
ce qu'on a ici balle et les ampoules
connectés qui viennent très clairement
frontale par rapport au phillips you ça
va ça va enfin c'est la grosse pomme et
rick on l'avait déjà vu moi j'utilise à
la maison c'est pas mal au début ça
c'est son chrono à sensations mais au
final on s'y fait pèse personne
connectée et vous avez même des salariés
de toilette banques ou par contre je
trouve ça alors un peu cher au niveau du
prix on est à 45 euros pour avoir un
pacte des serviettes
ouais bon ça ça a l'air très sympa mais
50 euros quand même pour avoir deux
serviettes de toilette et de serviettes
de bain bon je ne suis pas un acheteur
compulsif de servette mais je suis pas
sûr et là on a tout un corner enfants
avec la construction de jouer schumi
c'est c'est hallucinant de se rendre
compte de tout l'écosystème tout ce
qu'il faut ça et même de la trottinette
enfants je découvre en même temps un sac
à dos shiomi sac à dos en pvc alors
savez si remis en fait on plaint de
d'entreprises avec lesquelles il
travaille d'entreprise qu'ils un cube
d'entreprises partenaires
et une fois qu'ils ont des produits
aboutis il les commercialisent eux
directement
c'est un peu leur force de frappe est ce
qui leur permet d'avoir une offre
extrêmement large et de retrouver des
produits très tech complètement mélanger
voyez adea typiquement des jeux en bois
des choses sur lesquelles on n'irait pas
du tout cherché la marque assez sympa et
là on a deux vidéos proche qu'on avait
déjà vu lorsqu'on était à milan qu'on a
revu plusieurs fois le purificateur
d'air pour ça c'est un peu moins
surprenants sont déjà connus depuis plus
longtemps
les power band chimie ont fait le beau
jayson avec le casque comme ça on pose
un ce que la classe à dallas bravo belle
performance monsieur de l'enceinte
connectés et des chaussons connais un
petit peu moins on a des selfs eastick
des tripodes dans pareil en termes de
prix sont toujours extrêmement bien
positionné ça a l'air d'être quand même
assez sympa mais ça je connaissais pas
j'ai du coup complètement c'est l'acte
sean kane 4k de schumi qui à 130 euros
et vous avez sanguine ball juste à côté
à 120 euros
la petite coque pour le rend
complètement waterproof et les batteries
de recharge à 10 euros alors là on a
tout un corner smartphones et si c'est
forcément le le coin le fond de la pièce
avec tous les produits smartphones qui
sont connus lepoko fun f1 qu'on connaît
forcément qu'on reconnaît tous les
produits smartphones le nouveau produit
du moment le mime x3 on va se tester
d'ici quelques jours
son prédécesseur le mix de skf toujours
d'actu qui est franchement très très
bien comment il va là toute la partie
avec leurs ennemis notre 6% on en a déjà
parlé
excellent rapport qualité prix leur
ennemi si ça juste là leur ennemi s ii
forcément mis à deux est mis à dos light
le 1008ha ya toute une partie à monde
connecté avec l'ami band 3 à la grimace
fit avec la ps la stratos 2 et il faut
le reconnaître quand même la vue pas
dégueulasse sur les champs-elysées je
crois que là franchement on a connu pire
comme boutique c'est quoi l'idée dessus
au milieu
l'idée c'est vraiment de montrer une
image haut de gamme de sortir un peu des
clichés marques chinoises on marque low
cost marque pas cher avec des produits
qui serait forcément assez moyen montrer
une image hyper premium se niveler à la
hauteur des samsung et apple avec sa
propre boutique sur les champs elysées
ça c'est vraiment le premier point est
le deuxième point c'est vraiment de
vouloir inscrire la présence en europe
et notamment en france avec justement
cette boutique situé dans l'avenue la
plus prestigieuse de france l'avenue des
champs-elysées donc on a vraiment un
double objectif d'une montre
effectivement que c'est du premium
c'est du haut de gamme ça fonctionne
c'est vraiment bien et qu'on peut
compter sur eux et les produits sont
vraiment bien la deuxième c'est vraiment
s'inscrire dans la durée en france en
tout cas le message qui est passé
aujourd'hui par shiomi avec ses
boutiques et franchement énorme situé au
30 32 avenue des champs elysées et là
pour le coup on doit dire que
l'opération séduction est franchement
plutôt bien réussi
après il ya des trucs dans lequel finit
par se perdre un petit peu c'est à
comprendre pourquoi est ce que je suis
on me va vous proposer des services
coûtent 4 servier 50 euros alors écoutez
son petit de prix dit agressif sur deux
lampes ou connectez vous connecter la
journée ici la salle à une l'équivalent
du philip sion philips d'être trop de
45,50 euros l'an cool
là on a 19 99 une vraie politique de
prix hyper agressive est là pour vous
avec les serviettes à 49,99
ça paraît quand même relativement cher
puisqu'ils ainsi s'en prenant également
de la partition oui c'est de se
retrouver avec une boutique où vous avez
de smartphone vous avez récemment les en
plus connectés et électrique vous avez
du vélo vous avez la serviette et vous
avez des jouets pour enfants dans des
poussettes et les trentenaires pour
enfants en un peu de mal on se perd un
peu
alors c'est leur politique c'est là leur
fonctionnement en chine de se dire on a
une offre qui fait ralentir tous qui va
concerner votre vie mais c'est vrai
quand on arrive dans une boutique on
verra celle électronique ans plus tard
en france un succès à mon sens nous
aurons deux vices revient sur ses
comptes
dans un bisse tort et on se retrouve
avec des jeux pour enfants alors
pourquoi pas ça pose pas problème
mais c'est vrai que ça brouille un peu
le message est des fois c'est un peu
moins compréhensible pour moi car ces
trucs de la part du grand public
je vois mal une famille a révisé à pia
cherisma et acheter un jouet pour les
enfants abaca unissant les champs st par
un peu compliqué après sur un achat
additionnel pourquoi pas voila apres c
c'est le fonctionnement de la marque
ils ont tiré une gamme électronique à
l'é tat 95% dans un peu plus compliqué à
quantifier en tout cas mais vous trouvez
que des petits accessoires en plus comme
ça pourquoi pas alors qu'est ce qu'on en
pense de cette boutique sur les champs
c'est magnifique c'est épuré ouais c'est
très sympa des coûts et surtout il ya
plein de produits et vendus
il n'y a pas que du téléphone il ya du
tout et brosse à dents même des
serviettes de toilette dessin lait de
toilette
ouais des cons c'est là qu'il me tarde à
autre chose l'après monsieur gros free
par exemple ça vibre fort ça vibre
forcée des bretons et pas seulement moi
j'en utilise uniquement grosse année
puisque juge pas cela ne nous regarde
pas ça va ça se passe bien oui et de
toula bernigaud téléphone je suis je
viens de tourisme est aussi bon meilleur
mobile
bien sûr toujours présent restez
connectés et en gros mc aussi et se
rendre hommage ce match qui les boudent
comme ça là
but et qui voit la mairie qui voit là ça
va
quoi
là il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de monde devant le nouveau
mister des champs-elysées beaucoup de
monde à vos livres ils ont tous des
c'est pas les bonnets rouges et 6 et les
bonnets aux anges c'est pas léger les
jeunes ce sont bien les bonnes et orange
d'ailleurs la crs sont pas très contents
vous avez pas mal de véhicules de crs
parce qu'ils voulaient distinguer
l'arrière en disant il ya un
attroupement on vient on sécurise donc
tout ce beau monde vient pour le
lancement du mr shiomi regarde plein de
choses à récupérer un truc qui va tout
cas super coup et puis je viens de la
boutique et franchement on va pas se
mentir
allez hop on est devant le siège de
microsoft à paris là là juste là parce
qu'on part la semaine prochaine à
londres aux belles c'est un événement
tech éducation par microsoft ça va être
hyper cool donc là l'idée c'est un petit
peu de préparer tout ça de voir à quoi
ça va ressembler comment on va
s'organiser ce qu'on va dire de caméras
ça va être hyper cool et je vous emmener
avec moi et vous allez voir ta leur
donnant rendez-vous un peu sulfureux un
peu cool enfin vous verrez dans quelques
instants
alors que tu manges de bhola je mange un
poisson qui va être
je ne sais pas lequel on mange très très
bien c'est cruel si cher avec des herbes
des petites graines des gnocchis aux
morilles un bon écoute merci beaucoup
s'est pareillement la même chose tassé
l'espace optimisée de chambre le film et
colbert en soit c'est chez toi utile
donc là c'est l'espace de ce rouge
microsoft d'accord on va un peu tout ce
qui se fait en ce moment il va y en a
pas mal de choses qui vont arriver d'ici
quelques temps
c'est énorme c'est là c'est fait c'est
presque le paradis ça m'impressionne
saleur l'application son campus au
pasteur pour allaiter rendez vous ça
c'est qu'en interne en personne peut la
télécharger
c'est génial alors qu'est ce qui se
passe lors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a
organisé un forum diversité inclusion
chez microsoft france donc c'est
vraiment sur des collaborateurs pour
partager
sensibiliser expliquer ce qu'on fait
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'activité sur la
diversité et l'inclusion chez les croise
en france et on avait envie de
recommuniquer tout ce qu'on fait pour
l'ensemble des collaborateurs et puis on
espère donner envie à certains de nous
rejoindre dans ses différents piliers
puisqu'on travaille sur
la diversité de gens sur la diversité
liées au handicap aux yeux il ya une
partie d'une grosse partie lgbt lgbt
c'est notre nouveau pilier dernier-né
puisqu'on a lancé en fait gleam france
d'angle ims est globale et djibouti
abrite microsoft corp maintenant c'est
gleam en france donc des équipes sont à
fond pour la tenue d'activités et puis
on a aussi un petit les générations ça
travaille et l'intergénérationnel parce
que
les haches et microsoft sa part de 22
ans ça va jusqu'à 60 ans et donc on m'en
fait bosser toutes ces générations
ensemble et qu'on capitalise surtout sur
le potentiel et
l'énergie de chacun on est handicapé
vous me disiez aussi le handicap absolue
dans la sensibilité le handicap
en interne aussi comment est-ce qu'on
crée un environnement des personnes
handicapées qu'elle est un handicap
visible ou invisible
bien inclus et qu'on soit attentif aussi
bien sûr à ces handicaps là que si sur
l'extérieur l'éducation fait plein de
trucs sur la dyslexie par exemple
aider les jeunes les personnes qui sont
dyslexiques ou potentiellement détecter
comme cela pourrait par les aider à
mieux étudier tout simplement wisco
[Musique]
on
à qui
bon là je vous dis pas où je suis je
suis dans une entreprise parisienne
pas très loin de la tour eiffel on
regarde pour faire des choses ensemble
qu'on va publier je vous en dis pas plus
on en reparle plus tard voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui je vous invite à me
dire ce que vous pensez vous de ce
cette nouvelle boutique de chez audi est
ce que c'est un truc qui vous intéresse
c'est ce que vous pouvez y aller sur les
champs et puis il faut rester connecté
parce que d'ici quelques jours on va
parler de shlomi on a tout nouveau
produit qui est là tout beau tout chaud
c'est le ministre wallon en mx3 on va le
tester aurait déjà pris en main ya
quelques temps on va se le tester puis
là je vous laisse parce que profitent du
beau temps parisien va aller bronzer on
va aller se baigner za du cinéma voilà
donc vous invite à lire tout ce que vous
pensez de cette nouvelle boutique xiaomi
en ligne et vous donne rendez vous très
très prochainement début de semaine
prochaine
on part mardi soir j'aurai avec moi on
va à londres on va un événement
microsoft éducation tech qui va être
hyper intéressant en avoir plein de
choses ça va changer un peu de ce qu'on
fait habituellement
et franchement ça va être aidant et là
je vous laisse avec la tour eiffel en
toile de fond c'est juste magnifique
voilà soyez sages prendra fin bientôt
oui
[Musique]